it is one of those things where we'll we
will agree to disagree
on that and i think that it's probably
as well because we're button heads on
things
and you know if he's helping people and
if fasting is helping those people
it that's fine and again it's not like a
war where
i have to conquer jason fung we're just
two people that
should be allowed to butt heads on
things because ultimately his team are
fasting hungry people that can't sleep
because their adrenals are [ __ ]
firing
you do you guys if you like that then
you [ __ ] do that
but then i've got my my camper people
over here they're like [ __ ] out i
lost six pounds in the last three weeks
eating cereal every day
you know what i mean so like we have our
camps we have our people
welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
episode 88 with james smith
james smith is an online personal
trainer with a huge following
i started following him on instagram i
can't remember why
but i needed to have him on because we
do not agree on diet
and i thought that might be fun he has
anti-keto stuff up and anti-fasting and
i thought
why not it was a blast we ended up
agreeing to disagree on a number of
things and got
super super sidetracked into
psychedelics goodbye youtube ads for
this
episode and airfryer's pregnancy pillows
we covered a lot one day i will make him
gluten free
just wait james this episode is brought
to you by selfauthoring.com
i wanted to mention self-authoring
because james is an author and so i
figured that was appropriate
self-authoring was developed by my dad
over the last 30 years with help from
two other phds at mcgill and harvard
the self-authoring suite is a series of
online writing programs that
collectively help you explore your past
present and future
if you ever get stuck in your head and
can't figure out what's going on around
you
which can happen if you've recently been
through something that makes no sense
something like self-authoring can help
you try and make sense of your life
it has past authoring which covers your
past present authoring with
two modules the first helps you
understand and rectify your personality
faults
the second helps you understand and
develop your personality virtues
and the future authoring program helps
you envision a meaningful healthy and
productive future
three to five years down the road and to
develop a detailed implementable plan to
make that future a reality
use code mp to get 10 percent off at
selfauthoring.com
codemp enjoy this conversation i
certainly did
[Music]
james smith welcome to my podcast thank
you very much for having me i'm
incredibly flattered to be here
well thank you thank you very much i'm
really excited about this
i generally start off if i don't forget
by just asking
my guests to give a very brief
background about who they are and
what they do so i'm a personal trainer
by trade coming up to about 10 years
on the gym floor a very ordinary
personal trainer role
and for years i was just accumulating
thousands of hours of doing that and
kind of learning the practice
and then i moved to australia about four
years ago
and when i came here i started using
social media and i think that
i very much got the timing right where
social media was starting to boom
and i started putting out helpful
content on the internet
and it's all got incredibly carried away
and i'm now in a position
where i've got a large following and i
run a online training academy where
in essence the kind of information that
i feel people need
isn't easily accessible for people and
it's a very
shrouded area and there's a lot of
people being misled for financial gain
so i pretty much
make a profession out of trying to
provide clarity for people and making it
accessible
okay so do you think you got started do
you think it's more important to
post regularly to get followers
or to be creative like what are
what do you think it's an interesting
one it's like an ongoing experiment for
myself and i think that
very much in the onset when it came to
creating content
it was one post a day of someone's
question i was asked and i thought to
myself
if i can't think of one bit of content
to post today i'm probably in the wrong
job
and if someone asked me something even
if really trivial or simple on the gym
floor
i thought if this person's paying me and
asking me this then you know
clones of that person who are going to
have the same problems are probably
thinking it
and it allowed me to tap into potential
customers and
prospects by doing so now arguably i'd
say that that approach
isn't always the most linear
for growth but it is probably the most
linear for business
and i think that on social media at the
moment a lot of people do get carried
away with
you know women taking photos of their
bum and sticking it on instagram is
going to get you far more engagement
it's probably going to get you far more
followers
but it's not going to get clients coming
in through the door and
for dudes as well they're getting their
top off and you know getting a bit of
baby oil on and taking pictures with a
pump it's going to get more engagement
and we're almost caught up in this world
of people letting their egos
and these gratification likes shares
comments getting in the way of
actually what the sole purpose of social
media was for in the onset and that was
helping people
if i post a bikini picture i get
10 times as much engagement 10 times
i think it's it there are a lot of
things going on in behind the scenes i
think at first
people will stop and i think that the
algorithms play into that it's a
scrolling
effect and they're going to stop and
then they're going to recognize your
face then they're going to see you in a
bikini and
they're going to maybe a bit of shock
and awe because of the usual content you
put out whether it's
you know assets from that's true podcast
things and then
i actually think there's if people zoom
i think that plays into the algorithm
too
so not not saying people are perving
they probably could be
maybe are they could be pinching the
algorithm goes hold on
they've just stopped on michaela
peterson's picture for seven seconds and
pinch to zoom boom and then they're
going to
look to the rest of your followers and
put you higher up in that algorithm
saying
you know these 40 of men that are in
america's stopped and pinched and spent
30 longer
let's show it to the other collective
part of our audience who might not have
seen one of your posts for a few days
oh i never thought about that that might
count as engagement
so you should hide things in your photos
yeah well
you can but then you run the risk of uh
not
this is a crazy thing and it's again
this is all speculation from me i don't
work in
coding or engineering when i start a
video i have to capture someone
in that 15 seconds before it pauses and
asks them to open it into an instagram
tv so
i've been playing around with swearing
in the onset showing frustration
uh facial emotions without talking and
then i
they were like little petri dishes that
i have stacked around that
i'm like well if i start off going
[ __ ] bastards wasting my time
people are they're in and the video
duration lengths are much better
or if i start off saying what's really
pissing me off today it's like people
are drawn to
these emotions or it's crazy but yeah
that first 15 seconds or
the photo image putting text over it
it's really interesting to find out
what captivates your audience
that is so interesting i haven't been
paying attention to any of that i'm just
starting to pay attention to it now
like oh this is something i should
probably learn i don't really want to
learn this i just want to
post content that i want to post but
then i'll find something
extremely interesting i'll post it up
and i'll be like why does no one else
care
is it me am i strange am i missing the
algorithm
maybe all of it like i don't know it's a
it's an interesting one where it's
changed over the years from being time
based where
in my early days i had to wait until a
certain time and post something
and then uk were waking up yeah now it's
now it's i'm not too bothered i think
that similarly to
uh email marketing people worry about
when they send it i'm like just just get
it out there because when they open
their laptop
to do their emails whether it's been
sitting in there for nine minutes or
nine hours i don't think that's going to
impact
the person's experience with the email
and
it's quite good that social media now
does have these algorithms to kind of
help us
where you can go to bed and wake up and
be in a different time zone and still
you know not lose your canadian
followers when you're in a dubai time
zone
but yes it's a really interesting
experiment and you're never really
taught
how to do it how you should do it the
ethical
kind of part to it i spend a lot of time
helping personal trainers saying
stop getting your ass out there because
people get very distracted that social
media is a tool for business
and if you use it as just a way to
polish your ego or for gratification you
can lose sight of
why you use it and it can be a very kind
of toxic tool
and i remind personal trainers you're
looking to get clients you're looking to
generate business and you're looking to
you know have a sales funnel in place
and i often i'm quite crass and i joke
and i say to people like
your marketing and social media should
be like trying to get laid and often
people that are good at getting laid
are good at selling themselves because
they appreciate that
go onto a dance floor talk to 10 people
get five numbers organize two dates get
sex once
and then and social media they're gonna
go
uh put out five videos uh
end up getting 100 email addresses
through my link and bio
end up sending 15 emails 10 sales
whatever it is
and these funnels exist everywhere and
so many people
are using social media to polish their
ego to see
what angle of lighting and you know what
kind of oil they could put on post pump
to get the most likes
and in this very skewed dimension
of raising their own gratification
points
almost they're skewing normal people's
ideas of what a good body looks like
what a physique should look like
and it's kind of a bit messed up in my
mind that
these people at the top with fantastic
physiques and big followings
don't even know they're doing this
they're so caught up in their own photo
shoots and their own angles and their
pumps and their
12-week shreds or whatever that normal
people that pick up their smartphones
and
are exposed to these physiques it's
really you know
skewing what we perceive
normal to be i'm a bit torn in that
aspect
because i think it's social media at
least especially for women
all the photos are edited right like so
so that's a huge issue
but then there's also an aspect that it
gives you an ideal to
try and like find although if the ideal
is
edited then that's that's an issue uh i
think what you said about
business i'm wondering if it's different
for if you have male or female audiences
do you know if your audience skews male
or female
my majority audience is female about 70
it used to be about 75
a lot of people could be surprised by
that i just saw your your face there
i'm surprised yet although i can come
across i don't know why i'm surprised
i have an avatar in my mind so i know
who my dream client is
she existed before on the gym floor her
name's susan
she's married uh you know she's done a
lot of diets before
she's between 30 and 40. i know so much
about susan and every post i post is
actually aimed at susan
so i talk about dress sizes i talk about
the frustrations of
pulling your top down when you stand up
the frustrations of always choosing
black
and for four or five years every post
without people realizing has actually
been
speaking to susan and because of that
it the majority of my audience will most
almost fit into that category so it's
intentional in that sense i much prefer
training
women and probably my split on the gym
floor was 70
women probably 30 men so it's almost
indicative of
the efforts and the practices i had
before
that's so interesting i have
i have absolutely no goal like i've
talked to a bunch of marketing companies
about you know
brand alignment or trying to make things
more consistent across platforms which
is something i'm working on
and they're like well who's your target
audience it's like i don't
i have no idea who my target audience is
people who are like open to new ideas
which is a little
vague i feel like you have to you have
to know them or you have to get to try
and understand who they are because
ultimately if you want to be good at
sales you need to present pain points to
people
and i always use chiropractors as a
really good uh
you know example of this a chiropractor
knows your pain point before you come in
because unless your back's a bit dodgy
you're not going to the chiropractors
you come in they go right how can we
make this pain point worse they go
what's the problem oh my back hurts i
can't do this i can't do that
okay cool before we present the solution
let's get you to do an x-ray
do an x-ray and you don't know what
you're looking at and they go oh yeah
disc degeneration oh look at these these
lumbars are a bit too close together oh
you know
oh how old are you 30 though this
spine's looking like 50. people are
there like oh no my life's over i'm
gonna have to get a spine replacement
and then they go look for only 100 a
week you come in we're going to give you
an adjustment and you present the
solution because
once you can tap into these pain points
the sale is so much easier
and as a pt when people sit down i'm
like okay what are we working towards to
go up
got a wedding in august i want to fit in
this dress
and then when they're pushing back on
price or you know i'm not sure if i can
commit
you can bring that pain point back up
now for an effective
social media strategy not to be like
you're not going to fit in that red
dress and you know what i mean like
it just to say look you said that was
important you said this meant a lot to
you
um and i think that when running a
business online
having that person in mind makes it a
lot easier um
and you can almost communicate with them
a lot more especially when it comes to
presenting
a product okay
i know that i just don't have like i
don't have the umph yet i also don't
have anything for sale
yet one day the i've heard you
mention uh the self-authoring uh
program the yeah so
that's great that's my dad's though like
i mean it's it's great but i mean it's
kind of a family business but that's
mainly my dad so
i do like that product though and this
is something where
uh whenever i whenever i see something
that's why i have interest in it
i always like to put myself in their
shoes i get excited and i think about
how i could
like sell it what pain points you'd go
in like how you would
tap out people i did a i don't do much
paid advertising but i did one when i
first got to sydney
and i put in it wouldn't it be nice to
have more than your face in your tinder
picture
and it was quite people see it and be
like
the majority of people like you [ __ ]
but a lot of people would go
hold on it would hit a pain point they
would go i am just putting my face in my
in my tinder picture i am
you know hiding my body from what is a
visual representation of who i
am and it's on an app which is
encapsulating another pain point that
they're single so i was always trying to
tap into those things to try and get an
emotional response from people
where they would not necessarily go let
me get my purse out but they would go
hold on this
guy understands the problems and pains
i'm facing
if he understands the pain the pains and
the problems he's probably more in
more likely to understand or have the
solutions i need
ah that's interesting okay i kind of do
that with diet
but i don't do it as in are you
suffering from that
i say this is what happened to me
and then i think people who identify
with that
are sometimes drawn towards it but it's
not
yeah in in your sense with uh
the carnivore uh lion diet
i think that's exactly the way to do it
i'm not criticizing your approach with
that because
uh if i was to talk about i'm sure we're
going to delve into it i'm sure it's in
the show notes but
i have this saying where i go if you
hear hooves think horses
not zebras and i say to people that if
you're a tear like
outside you wouldn't go ask a zebra
outside the front you'd be like
you'd be like it's probably a a horse
and
i think that with specialist diet advice
that's where a lot of the time
you know when there's something
potentially anecdotal
because we've had a few conversations
offline about the nature of
nutrition and the subjectivity of it and
there is this kind of grey area between
objectivity and
subjectivity and yeah i think when it
comes to diet that's a great way and i
think that's why
when trainers are you know
uh transparent with the
journey they've been through it can
really help people they go but this
worked for me
and that can work in the good side on
one side but on the other side
it can feed people's confirmation bias
of certain systems
such as low carb such as sugar free such
as
not eating after 6 pm and after a while
if you feed your bias enough it becomes
like a personal belief
and it's very hard to let go of i
completely agree have you ever tried any
of these diets
like have you have you done tests on
yourself not really
if i'm completely honest and i'll put my
hands up and you know i'm not gonna lie
to people and go
yeah i did vegan it was [ __ ] and there
are times that i think i would like to
experiment the carnivore diet has always
fascinated
me a bit but i pride myself on
i take it very personally at training
when i don't perform well uh
i can i train yeah brazilian jiu jitsu
maybe six seven times a week
and i know that there's going to be a
pain point of a few weeks i know already
that if i go super low carb and in
predominantly meat based
that i'm going to suffer and it's that
suffering that
for the sake of an experiment i think i
could struggle with uh yeah i think most
people struggle with it and it is the
very very very rare individual that
well it if it's a very rare individual
that just feels better when they start
i have seen that happen but for people
who are
exercising all the time and are
generally healthy
um the switch from like a standard diet
and then going into ketosis usually has
some sort of
dip if i if if people feel better it's
usually because they're
they're really really really suffering
yes
it's one of those things where i think
that if people are training at
relatively low intensities
i think that absolutely and if it's
going to help people create a calorie
deficit and help them sustain a weight
loss diet
i think all form but i think that when
we look into the realms of athletes
which is a very very small percentage of
people and i did just call myself an
athlete there
quite happy that i've just said that out
loud james you're just nice to yourself
then
uh then i love i love utilizing things
like cereal
and like objectively speaking i know
that cereal
isn't nutrient dense i know it's not you
know
a great food but for me waking up from a
nap knowing i've got training in an hour
it's one of my things that i love and
having to say goodbye to bread and
cereal would be quite a sad time for the
sake of an experiment
jesus i haven't had cereal since 2015.
i think if i had cereal now i would die
i don't know what would happen it would
be terrible
i mean you know i first when i started
uh
first understand understanding the
conditions in which you've had the
dietary changes you've had
like if someone said to me oh james i'm
thinking of going
completely pretty much just eat meat and
similar to
your dad as well and he said your old
man that's a british thing when we say
your dad you say you're old man
so i'm like oh yeah me old man and i
know he said it then i think that if you
have any uh canadian
listeners as well they'll be like old
man um
if someone's like i'm just gonna eat
beef i'd be like hold on let's sit down
let's talk about this
but again it's the case of the zebra and
i think that a lot of
my followers are going to come this way
and listen to this episode there's i've
got a lot of excitement about coming on
speak with you
how quick
was that change you know for you in what
2015 that
got moving into just this meat based
diet and do you have anything do you
have eggs
no i can't do eggs i can tell you like
vaguely vaguely what happened is i first
i went gluten free because i
found out i had the celiac gene and was
like oh
maybe i have celiac disease and that's
causing the arthritis so first i went
gluten-free for about i think it was
about three months
and then i went down to a paleo diet
which was
it was a lot of i like love greens so
there's a lot of greens
um root vegetables meat all types of
meats little fish
um and i kind of just tried to eliminate
things i knew people were allergic to
like actual allergies so eggs were
definitely out dairy was out
grains were out legumes were out and so
i went really restricted and i did that
kind of thing
for about a year and a half
and then i went to meat and greens and i
did that for a year
and a bit and then i went to meet so it
was like
i started dieting june 2015. i went
pretty restrictive september 2015 and i
went to the carnivore diet
december 2017. so i like i went down
slowly and
i don't know if i like i don't know if i
i know people who go from the standard
american diet to carnivore
but um i don't know if i would have been
able to
do it because even just restricting
carbs was
really really really hard and it made me
feel better incrementally
but uh it was not easy i can't imagine
what would have happened if i just
jumped in
um i probably would have felt better
faster
but i don't know what that transition
would have looked like it wouldn't have
been pretty it wasn't pretty for the
those like number of years and i think a
lot of my
problems came from the abrupt cessation
of ssris
which gave me serious psych problems i
didn't know that ssris had withdrawal
and that kind of sensitized me to my dad
had the same thing to light
to temperature to sound sound terribly
and to anything that was more
inflammatory that i was eating
so when i tried to kept trying to
reintroduce carbs and i kept having
these horrible like depressive episodes
that doesn't happen anymore like i've
tried to test these things out those
psych symptoms don't happen anymore
but they did for about two and a half
years so i think that was ssri
withdrawal and i've talked to some
psychiatrists about that
the arthritis is still still a problem
but that's like that's a serious problem
and i haven't figured out how to get rid
of that
but i think a lot of the the zero carb
diet that i
was kind of like forced onto was to
treat ssri withdrawal
that's the background it's so
interesting to talk to someone who first
hand
is experiencing the connection between
digestion and
like mental well-being where i find that
a lot of
gut practitioners they what they bore
the [ __ ] out of me when they talk
i can't you know they're like the
microbiome and the microbiota and like
you know
all of these things and like oh that's
gonna have a detriment to the gut to
microbiota i'm
shut up like this is this is boring and
there's a lot of these like
authoritarian people in this in these
industries they don't look healthy
and it's it that is kind of almost
discriminating and prejudice against
them
and um but then when people then
speculate about the connections between
it
i actually find it amazing that you can
say i'm having
you know mental changes
occurring from the types of food that i
eat and i think that even just having
that kind of discussion with people can
now
allow people to think more so after
they've eaten
and see how do i feel from certain foods
how do i feel when i have these have
this
um because ultimately we're very
varied with our what we like when it
comes to food and how we feel after
certain foods
yeah i think i think it would have
helped me when i was younger if i had
just known
that that was a possibility because i
grew up thinking
you know it's it's purely it's
purely calories purely and that
and it really wasn't for me particularly
because of the celiac disease right
because i so you know if you have that
then you can't eat anything with gluten
period right and i didn't know that
until i was about 23.
so if i had just been if i just heard
someone say hey there might be a
connection that you could at least rule
out
which is what i did when i was 23. i was
like i was trying to go down all the
routes
to to figure out this autoimmune
disorder because i was like i can't keep
living like this i can't keep living
like this
and i thought well i might as well rule
out diet
and that was just where i started
because i was like just get that factor
out of the way if it has nothing to do
with diet i'll go down all the other
routes
um and i when i started i had absolutely
no idea it had anything to do with diet
until i hit the celiac thing and then i
i did the next part i did low carb
because my mom dragged me to a
naturopath
and the naturopath gave me this list of
foods to eat and i was like this makes
no sense this makes no sense like why
can i not have oranges but lemons are
okay
like that doesn't make any sense and it
was so aggravating i was like why can i
have some nuts but not other nuts
like um and so i came up with my own
list that made more sense in my head
which was just
you know cutting out i cut out nuts too
right like anything that i could be
allergic to and it
ended up taking me down this route um
so it's been a while right any kickback
from say like vegans where you know
there's there's this almost anti-meat
propaganda going out there and you're
like i'm just trying to survive you're
like you know i'm just trying to live
here i found one food group
you're like let me live let me live yeah
as much fun as only eating one food
group is
uh you know what no i don't
i think that people who are more like
um everyone on the planet should do a
carnivore diet
like those people i think get a lot more
hate i have i've also like blocked the
occasional vegan that comes up and is
like
haven't you considered this and i was
like do you have arthritis that's
destroyed your joints
then [ __ ] off like um
so no but i've also i've probably
blocked maybe
six or seven uh oh i had
one person i'm not gonna mention him
because he's a following i've had one
person who really went after me when my
dad was really sick
and that was kind of hard
psychologically because i couldn't
handle any extra stress
but he's like i mean you can judge how
his well-being is by how he looks
yeah fair enough i think uh a lot of
people with this
uh meets got really bad rap over the
last few years and i like pointing out
to people that
studies in red meat especially are
observational
looking at populations as a whole and
when making judgments on populations you
can
create you know the association between
red meat and certain types of cancer
but i've said this to people that often
non-health-seeking people consume more
red meat
and more health-seeking individuals
consume less red meat and people like
what do you mean and i was like okay
burgers kebabs bacon sandwiches you know
fry up breakfasts all of these things
and i'm not saying like
never eat these things i'm saying that
these are more predominant in people who
probably just don't care
they probably get less sleep probably
stay up too late probably don't set an
alarm get up late for work
where health seeking people consume less
and association
and is not causation and i like saying
to people that
meat is a fantastic food and it should
be a staple of anyone's diet who wants
to have it there
and you know some people are well you
know you can't eat too much of it
because it's going to give you cancer
and
it annoys me because it
i love meat i think it's great i think
that and people have a right to eat it
just as much as
the vegans have the right to tell people
not to and i think it's something you're
brought up with
it's a staple part of your diet we need
to just leave people alone so it's quite
interesting to see because i
i get this i get flack for all the time
i like so imagine this this is part of
my uh strategy as well
i know that vegans are never gonna do
business with me so i make them easy
targets
same with keto no one's gonna come to my
plan and be like james take my money i'm
keto
right so i start little fights with
people i know that are never gonna do
business with me
that's terrible how do you sleep at
night
very well very well have you have you
noticed better than me
most uh for instance uh personal
trainers always worry about what other
personal trainers think about them
and that's the only person that's never
going to do business with you
they're losing sleep over that and i
think the business owners it's like
if you're a successful author should you
be worrying what another author thinks
because ultimately they're probably not
very likely to buy your book
they might do but ultimately the only
opinions you need to worry about are the
masses of people that are going to buy
it
and i think that we do get caught up in
this world where we worry about what our
peers think
and we need to ask ourselves if you know
what we're putting out there is actually
for them
oh i think completely differently than
that that's really interesting
like um i yeah i judge myself based
on what people i respect
think about me so people not not to say
that people watching aren't people i
respect
but people who i'm aiming to be like
i'm like what do they think about what
i'm doing which is a rough way to live
especially if you're aiming to be
somebody who's more successful than you
but that's who i'm aiming content for
i think it's uh that's a fantastic way
to i always think about that like uh
you know you got the the big dogs at the
top of the podcasting game you got joe
rogan
you always think if i went across his
desk tomorrow what's he going to be
thinking
but i think that he wouldn't give a [ __ ]
i think like you you just want if you're
ever in a day where you like creating
content or you're doing something you're
like if you want to come across the desk
of someone you admire
you want them to go fairfax yeah
the point about like losing sleep as
well is if you ever come across like a
bad review
i just straight away think about the
person that's left it and i go
they're probably not on the edge of
their seat are buying my products
they're probably not about to slip off
and become a customer
so am i worrying about the opinion of
someone who's not going to
benefit me the only thing it's going to
potentially do is polish my ego and
likes
and shares and comments not even that if
they're leaving a bad review
i think people are giving up too much
mental energy on the people that
don't pour into their glass if you know
what i mean
yeah i i completely agree um how often
do you get negative
if your audience is skews mostly women
do you think you have an easier time on
social media than somebody whose
audience
skews mostly male 1 i'm not actually
sure because
um i think that there is a kind of
a trend i can feel it i can sense it i
always have a
kind of sense these things i think men
are starting to realize for the first
time in a long time that they need help
and this is one of the reasons i hated
training men
because they never my engagements
weren't with them that james i can learn
from you men are very bad at learning
from other men and listening to other
men
i think men are just actually quite poor
at communicating amongst themselves
i think especially with work your dad's
done it's allowed
men to understand themselves but now i
feel that men are actually becoming more
open to learning they're becoming more
open to
lowering their ego and accepting that
people know more than them
and it sounds again i could probably you
know the [ __ ] misogynists are going
to come for me
i think women are more open to learning
from people and whether or not that's
because
you know my experience of working with
people on the floor
i think this barrier that men hold to
learning is coming down so i think that
it
i'm not sure which way it would go but
either way i think it would be quite an
interesting
kind of turn of events okay
i think i agree with you do you think it
has anything to do with how old are you
i'm 31. okay so i've been talking to a
lot of people i'm 29 i've been talking
to a lot of people who are between the
ages of like
well 25 and 40. and
i think it i think that sometime around
30
people start to get introspective and
they're like
instead of you know looking at hopefully
i think this would be a good quality
for somebody to have but i think instead
of looking outside and being like what's
everyone doing wrong
i've been talking to a lot of people
that have said oh you know i've had
these issues growing up or this is why i
react this way in certain situations
to try and improve themselves to improve
their relationships
so that's either that has i think it has
something to do with age but i think
it's also a trend or becoming more okay
right now which might have been what
you're picking up on
yeah i think the introspective is such
as soon as you say that i think about
psychedelics
and it's it i again condoning drug use
is a very
tricky thing to do but i can't believe
some of the
some of the coming of the experiences
that i've had with psychedelics have
given me introspective realizations i
think that a lot of people from the
outside they think you're seeing things
that aren't there and you're like oh my
god there's an elephant in my room or
or whatever it is but being someone who
spent the majority of my twenties with
these shields up
all the time you know bad history of
relationships
uh you know i'm now starting to
understand that
i probably see intimacy as as a way of
giving up my freedoms
and that i need to work on that if you'd
asked me five years ago
i was like nah these birds are mental
you know all of them are mental you know
like
it would have been so different and uh
there have been so many conversations
i've had with myself uh whether it's you
know
magic mushrooms or dmt and
it's crazy but you almost live life
through a lens of looking out
and when i've taken psychedelics it's
turned that lens back on myself and it
it's crazy when you take advice from
someone else it's almost diluted and
slightly watered down because it's not
you
and when i've had these conversations
with myself especially in my late 20s
and early 30s
you can't not listen because it's come
from you
and uh yeah the the introspective
reality that is probably not the society
it's probably not the structures it
probably is
me okay
we definitely need to get into this this
was not in my list of things to talk
about but i've had such wild
experiences with psychedelics that now
i'm not going to be able to monetize
this episode so
thank you for that but anyway i just got
re-monetized and
anyway it's fine it's fine i still want
to talk about it um
so okay
what exactly do i want to ask what was
your experience with dmt like versus
mushrooms it's not as committal
the word i'll say is okay with mushrooms
and lsd you have to
set time aside you have to create a low
stress environment
where um you know whether it's going to
the beach picking a good close group of
friends or just one friend
you need to write a day off i'd be very
busy with my stories in the first part
of the day because
people become very suspicious if i'm not
on my phone for the day
people go you okay if i don't story for
like four hours
with dmt i remember i had a date
at 7 00 p.m i had like an hour to kill
and i laughed and i messaged my friend i
said i'm i'm gonna i i got dmt in like a
vape
so it was like water looking substance
put in him and he goes
why are you doing that and i said i'm
gonna get answers to a question i
haven't thought of yet
and i did it on my own and
15 20 minutes later i'm completely back
to normal but with one thought in my
mind
and that one thought i'm still
dismantling now
every time i have time to myself or i'm
listening to music or or whatever it is
i'm just thinking about you know these
thoughts of conjured there so
for me to not have to give up a day to
get some introspective kind of reality
to not have to give up you know hours of
my schedule to
have these deep and meaningful thoughts
is really valuable
okay i need to get my hands on some of
this
i've i've only i've done like two types
of psychedelics aco dmt but it's
basically a pro drug to
it's to silicon so psilocybin so it's
kind of the same thing it's the same
like
four to six hours and and i don't like
micro dosing i've tried micro dosing a
lot
i don't like it i like the really
intense ones but then it's like six
hours and it takes like a year
that's how long it feels and it's just
it's too much
almost almost there's a beautiful moment
where you're not using your phone
and you're sat appreciating nature or um
last time me and my friends did it we
sat overlooking the sea
and you think yourself you're like wow
why did it take an illegal
at the moment substance for me to put
myself here and experience this with my
friends
you know if i called one of my mates and
go yeah let's grab some fruit and go
look at the sea
like what you know what do you mean uh
but then
after that kind of really beautiful
period you do get to a point where
you're like i
quite fancy reality now and there is
that dragon
like almost rough couple of hours where
you're not in but you're not out
and um yeah i mean if you have a
strategy in place to relax or whatever
that's fine but yeah for me it was good
for that because
it sounds bad again you're not getting
monetized for this let's just do it
i then said to some of my friends i was
like i want you to try this and i've
never said this with anything else if it
was
you know cocaine i would never say to a
friend oh you gotta get on this because
i appreciate the dangers same with
alcohol my friends they don't drink
i'm not like oh you need to drink or
whatever there's a few of my friends i
was like
i just want you to try this and the fear
that they have
is what they have to give to it and when
you say it's only 15 minutes
it allows them to kind of break down the
fears with something and
and i'm not saying it because i want
people to do illegal drugs i want it
because
i genuinely feel the value every day
of the thoughts that i had and i feel
like it's made me a better person
and sometimes i i just want them to
experience it as well
and i'm not sure if that's like a
selfish thing a selfless thing i'm i
still can't even figure it out
but i was like it's helped me so much i
wanted to help other people
it's like in first time i got an
electric toothbrush
like a good one i was like this is
amazing
i was like i bought everyone around me
electric toothbrushes
like everyone was like james what have
you sent me as like it's an electric
toothbrush
i was like this is this is making my
life so much better every day you need
to have it
do you have an air fryer uh i don't i
i'm okay if you think i'm i'm serious if
you think electric toothbrushes have
improved your life there's nothing
that's improved my life more than an air
fryer
it can cook everything you can cook
steaks perfect steaks from frozen
you just put it frozen in and flip it
once
there's no cleanup you can put it in the
dishwasher it's
life-changing you will never lose a
stove again
so does it just cook with hot air
i know it doesn't sound great but it's
not it's like a tiny little oven
so it has a fan at the top it's like a
tiny little oven but it gets to like 400
415 so it gets super hot
and you can't just put a steak in the
oven a frozen steak in the oven right
but you can put a frozen steak in the
air fryer it makes the best chicken
wings
you probably eat other things other than
steak and chicken so
it makes great like potatoes vegetables
it will change your world i'm actually
uh i'll
i'll take you up on that advice at the
moment i've i've had a very transient
few years because i'm not a permanent
resident of australia
so i'm okay i'm still i have to leave to
get an answer as well so i've got to
leave the bubble of noorkovid
back to the uk to get an answer but i
struggled to buy things i really wanted
to get an air flosser
but i live out of a suitcase technically
although i've been here for a year and a
half
if i can't take it on a plane it's just
gonna get given up if
if you go around my house my housemates
have all the items that i had to give up
when i had to go home
so that's my tv from 2018 going to
another room that's my tv from 2019
and i'm too nice to ask for them back so
i could buy a new tv every time i come
back
one of them's got an iphone that i was
using before or whatever it is so i
always have to be like if i got an air
fryer i think to myself where's that
going to go in the suitcase
you know my mom unpacking when i get
back to the uk james what on earth is
this oh it's an air fryer mum
so when i when i have a place that i'm
permanently
again i will make that investment to get
one
i get an air fryer whenever i travel
which seems
superfluous perhaps but
if i go out to a restaurant and order a
steak it's an
expensive steak so getting an air fryer
is like two meals and then if i can eat
from home and have
like high quality steak it saves it you
know it saves me the money anyway
and then i just leave the air fryer or
if i meet someone i just give
give them the air fryer or i'll leave it
next door outside and just leave a note
on it
i feel like you're welcome this will
change your life
air fryers wherever i go i'll uh i'll
definitely get one i'm the same with
pregnancy pillows
they've changed my life sleeping with
pregnancy pillows and
uh people come into my room especially
if i'm like dating or like you know and
someone eventually comes back to the the
house they're like what's this
i was a pregnancy pillow i was like it's
just
perfect for a side sleeper such as
myself i can turn it into like a little
round dinghy and laying it when i'm
watching tv and people think you're
mental but you're like nah
i'm the same way for my last book tour
on the rider
it was like pregnancy below so i'd send
them to where i was going i said oh i'm
going to be in this part of the world
amazon send a pregnancy pillow to where
i was staying because i sometimes don't
trust hotel's pillow arrangement
i actually feel exactly the same way i
used to travel with a pillow
because it was a flat memory foam pillow
and i don't like the really poofy ones
under my head
um and yeah like a a large pillow
between my legs for side sleeping so i
completely understand
this is uh interesting i could be the
first person to ever do this but
i'm very fortunate in uh my line of work
now where i can
fly in parts of the plane where i can
stretch my legs out but if you fly in
business class
uh although you get lay flat bed they
give you the smallest pillow
that is mostly there just as a cushion
it's not even a proper pillow and even
if they do
so i took a pregnancy pillow with me on
a flight from england
to australia and as i'm like kind of you
know making the seat flat the the
hairstylist is looking at me
she's like is that a pregnancy pillow i
was like yes it is and
i was the comfiest person at 37 000 feet
you've ever seen
on there side sleeping with a pregnancy
pillow that's all my bag was my hand
luggage
was me just cramming a pregnancy pillow
into a backpack
i think that's probably a good use of
space i think that airlines moving
forward
that if you want to maximize the
experience of your your customers
there's a pain point there
the pain point is your rubbish pillows
you can upsell them
on a in-flight pregnancy pillow look at
that
saving lives and backs put chiropractors
out of business the bastards
okay okay we got a little we got a
little sidetrack there
what questions do i have to okay okay
this is these are
personal training questions that i i
want to ask because i've been
i've i haven't i really haven't trained
well for most of my life because i was
so sick and then i had multiple
surgeries which really
which really make training difficult if
you like if it just hurts you
but i'm better now so how often
well first of all the people who come to
you are they generally healthy
like are these generally healthy people
it's it's a tough one and i mean there's
so many debates we could get into now to
what health is
uh and you know it's another one of my
angsts with the world and the internet
where you know i could say this person's
not in a very good bit of health and
they go why'd you say that
i go because they're 40 50 kilograms
overweight
they're going but that doesn't mean
they're unhealthy i'm like well you know
i'm
looking and making assumptions from a
professional standpoint that if
someone's
got 50 kilograms of body fat chances are
their house isn't in order
you know the you know there's going to
be other underlying issues it's not just
over-consuming healthy foods so i'd say
people come in
on an array of a scale but they would
all say the same thing
that they want to better their situation
it's not like going
green to red it's like i want to improve
and that's my mindset
marginal gains you know i'll probably
have to wrestle hundreds of men in jiu
jitsu to get a bit of tape on my belt
you know that's all i'm worried about is
that next bit of tape
and it's the
there are people that come to me that
are very very overweight there are
people that come to me that are in
pretty good shape some of my clients are
in better shape than me and i feel like
a fraud when i help them
uh because they obviously need help with
like programming or weightlifting or
whatever
and i've got some guys in my academy now
i'm like [ __ ] you're in better shape
than me mate how can i help
you might need to go somewhere else
brother
well maybe they just need somebody to be
there with them to encourage them
yeah i think it's uh you know also even
some of the smartest and most brilliant
minds in the world
need someone to keep them in check just
to remain accountable
you know to say to them you've got your
work out his reps here's your sets
we're also very biased with our
programming we will give ourselves the
exercises we're good at
and we will subconsciously uh you know
just drown out any
if you're not good at front squats
they're never going to show up in your
programming which is why
i did crossfit for a bit not the like
bandana wearing but
when i was personal training in the gym
i was sick of the gym i needed to get
out and go somewhere else and i was
playing
semi-pro rugby and i was like right i'm
gonna go crossfit
and it i never looked at the workout
when they put it online because if i saw
it i wouldn't go
if it was like double underskipping or
whatever i wouldn't turn up
so i went blind to every crossfit
session i'd get there i'd look at the
board and i'd be like oh
god but i'd know that if i'd seen that i
wouldn't have turned up
but it was great after the workout to do
workouts that just had
unbiased programming and where i was
being given what the flavor of the day
was it wasn't up to me and
you know even if i'm there i'm not very
good at skipping so i'm there like a
flipping idiot
trying to learn how to do double unders
or whatever it was so yeah
i think people come from all varying uh
start points
but yeah people are they're just gonna
do what they're good at and
sometimes that's not what they need for
their goals
that's probably the opposite of what
they need right it's literally the
opposite of what they need if you're
good at an exercise
you should be doing the one that you
haven't got right or that
you're avoiding because it hurts in a
strange way
right it's the opposite i've had i have
a personal trainer right now and it's
so helpful it's so helpful because
i hate like from the injuries i've had
and i have like atrophied muscles in
certain areas or
i'm very like disbalanced um and
i hate it like emotionally hate it
but it having someone there that's like
yeah you know you can do this you're
improving
like and then who's watching me there i
can't leave early like i just have to do
it
i'm under pressure because i'm being
watched it's so helpful
um when you give people advice how often
do you tell them to start like how often
should they be going to the gym
i'm a big fan of you know if people
aren't training at all just go once
you know just go to the gym once a week
and i think working up to
three four workouts a week is is ideal
but again it's subjective and i've never
had kids
so i don't know the barriers first hand
of how that impacts your life
i think that one or two workouts a week
is still you know as long as you're
doing the work completely fine
and then if you have the luxury of
filling in the spaces between that then
good on you it's not gonna you know be a
detriment to it but yeah it's just uh
even going to the gym once a week the
full process of a muscle
you know damage recovery it's about
three four days
it's why muscle soreness never lasts a
week unless it's really extreme
so yeah like if you were to only train
once a week you'd probably have three
days that you're missing
but i don't think it's all about that i
don't think it's about the objective
nature of just training i think it's a
lot to do with identity as well
where when someone goes to the gym even
for once a week for 40 minutes
they're now a gym goer they're now
someone who has a grip of that element
of their life and
when i get people to hit step counts
it's not just about this arbitrary
number of steps that i've
10 000 you know do that it's that every
day they're working towards an identity
of being active
someone who's on their feet someone who
you know takes the stairs
and you know taking the stairs is such a
such a small thing to do when i started
work at my gym in
sydney that i was out a few years ago it
was three floors underground
and i remember one day i took the
elevator and i thought to myself if i
take the elevator i'm taking a shortcut
at work and i was like
i need to take the stairs every day no
matter what it is even just to get a
coffee i'm going to run up these stairs
and i was thinking because my identity
is someone that's not going to take
shortcuts it's not going to opt for the
easy ride that's not going to
you know just have the luxurious way of
doing it and
the whole time i was there i never took
the elevator after my first day
and it was an identity thing it wasn't
that i was going to burn seven calories
every time i went to get a coffee
and that's what the argument is that
people kind of sometimes throw against
you
oh it's just about burning calories it's
not it's about identity
it's about who you are it's about what
you become when you go to the gym
and i think that's often something
that's really overlooked by people
okay i can't help to but to say this
you're not taking shortcuts which is
true
but you're still eating gluten
containing grains
and i am so i have done so much research
about gluten containing grains i would
bet you good money
that even if you cut those out it would
make a difference to how you feel
and i think that eating cereal that
contains
gluten is a shortcut take it from
somebody who used to survive off of
cinnamon toast crunch which was which i
miss
dearly i ordered some of that on
actually saying that i did take a
shortcut the other day
i uh woke up from a nap and i uber eats
some cereal and i got a good diversity
of uh flavors i did i was struck
i was short on time i had to do some
work stuff and it literally was cost
efficient for me to do the work and pay
someone to bring me cereal
um this is the strange thing though for
me
when i uh carbohydrates i love consuming
them i feel great i can actually if i
have like a
a good feed and a nap i can train twice
in a day if i don't get that nap
i train in twice a day without a nap no
go
when i eat cereal yeah i feel amazing
i can eat a massive bowl a thousand i've
actually weighed it out i've done nearly
a thousand calories in a bowl of cereal
before like it's a big bowl
and i can go train and like my gut
loves it like it turns straight into
energy i can feel it coursing through my
veins
if i eat rice i'm like oh i'm a bit full
i feel like a little bit like of
the weight sitting in there i'm not even
sure what it is but
you know what objectively that's wild
it's just so it doesn't make you tired
afterwards no
and this is an interesting one this is
the debate which i'm sure you've you've
had some
interesting characters on your podcast
i've done a bit of homework
quite a few of them i don't really
i saw you went after jason fung today i
like jason fong i think he's brilliant
i i don't i like
i i don't um but agree to disagree
it you know you were saying that you
you're getting into your diet you're
getting into trying to figure out
everything that's going on the thing is
when we don't eat we're at this like
neutral baseline
and our neutral baseline for most
healthy humans is great
and when we eat there are not many
people
in the world that are saying we should
be energized after we eat
and even if we look at our central
nervous system we have fight or flight
and rest and digest
and even just looking at the rest and
digest it should be quite apparent that
we shouldn't be
filled with energy after we've just
eaten i think eating
makes us sluggish and i think that no
one is
okay so i i had an argument with someone
um who used to get tired after he ate it
was this was about
four years ago used to get tired after
he ate and this was when i was
first figuring it out and when i used to
eat i used to i didn't get
sluggish i'd pass out right like i
couldn't stay awake so it wasn't like oh
i'm relaxed it was
i'm going to fall asleep standing up so
that's that's in a different category
but i had an argument a number of years
ago with somebody who was like yeah i'm
tired after i eat like i have a nap and
i was like that's not normal i don't
think that's normal
and one thing's that's one thing that
changed even when i went to the paleo
diet
and i was still quite i wasn't on a
ketogenic diet when i first went to the
paleo diet because i was eating a lot of
um like salad and a lot of root
vegetables so it was low-carb but it
wasn't keto
and my fatigue after eating went away um
which was interesting i think you as a
as just somebody digging around i think
it's tricky because you said you had
jujitsu and i do agree that if you go
low low-carb
your body's gonna be like what the [ __ ]
are you doing but it's
really interesting to play around with
it and see what happens
because that fatigue i used to have like
i said extreme fatigue after i ate and
it went away completely and now i don't
have that at all
and it makes me so much more productive
because i don't have
any dips throughout the day that being
said i also don't train
like intensely twice a day and i think
if i did i'd need a nap
it's an interesting one where i and
again this is speculative i'm i'm not
trying to bring
objective arguments to the table i
actually don't like it when people were
trying to get the dick out too much with
like this study
1997 shows that but when
people eat and i could try i've tried
to get the kind of argument point that i
want i really should try
what you're saying and that's the only
way i can really get clarity and
you know if we talk again i can stand
here and go you were [ __ ] right or i
can say
nah or i tried it and you were not right
yeah yeah uh team cereal uh
team bread saved a sandwich but i hope
that it did doesn't make a difference
because i miss like if you do try i hope
it doesn't make a difference because
i think i think there's a lot of
cinnamon toast crunch
do you not feel that there's almost like
a bit of a a nice feeling to that lull
we're putting a lens on saying that
feeling sluggish after eating is a bad
thing but
you know sitting back in your chair yes
meal unbuttoning your jeans
having a little relaxing like oh god i'm
tired you know having
i think that's almost part and parcel of
it and i think that when people are
striving for clarity
let's not say fasting clears your mind
increases productivity reduces aging or
any of these things let's just say
eating is probably not a great idea if
you've got a lot on your plate in the
day
not so much that's the wrong metaphor to
use you know
if you've got a load of work to do
you're a bit stressed out probably not
the best time to eat you know eat later
in the day
i'm a bit hungry yeah cool but you've
got a lot of tasks that need attending
to
you'll be fine not eating at this point
i think that fasting has far too many
purported benefits
and then people like oh my god the
energy is amazing i feel so good and i'm
like well yeah of course you know you
just haven't eaten
um so yes it's one of those jo
i i probably do need to commit how how
long would you say that i'd need to
commit to
carnival the thing is for me i love me
in my mind it would be the guilt yeah
but
the gateway the guilt about what i would
think that this is too good because i'm
i have not got a good relationship with
vegetables
like i i don't look at vegetables and go
oh yum and i actually
i i'm a specimen when i was university i
lived off baked beans and sausage rolls
for like years i never got ill like my
diet was terrible
i would have just garlic bread as a meal
and my my i was playing rugby at rugby
uni my my mates were like
what are you having with that and i'm
like the whole loaf of garlic bread
and they were like where's you know i
didn't understand how to put a meal
together
so credit to my parents wow the way they
brought me up like
i was spoon-fed with meals every night
my parents whatever when i went to uni i
just ate crap
and yeah okay for me now i always feel
like i need to have the constituents of
vegetables this that
for me i feel like i'd enjoy my food
more if it was meat based
when i went to university i also ate
crap and i almost died
like it i gained like i gained
30 pounds in like a year and a half i
was i was underweight when i went
because i just had surgery so
i didn't get like i got chubby um and
but all my autoimmune symptoms and my
like psych symptoms
and my skin like everything just like i
uh it just almost killed me i was
deathly ill and then even when i went
back home
because i left university because i was
so sick i went back home and i went to
more of a standard diet
standard american diet because in
university i was like pizza
noodles these noodles called itchy band
that i really liked
like and cinnamon toast crunch and like
diet ginger ale and beer
like university diet and i went back
home and went to standard american diet
and even that made me feel better
um for you i don't know it depends
like most people i've seen who try the
carnivore diet do
feel pretty good but
they don't feel good in two weeks they
feel good in six weeks
so you can't do it for two weeks if you
do it for 10 days
i would say day 10 i you
it's hard to say but you'd probably not
feel as good as before on day 10
but if you wait till day 20 then people
generally
feel better but you like you you just
won't be able to tell until you try it
because it's absurd once you try it but
it's not the first month
or especially the first two weeks
they're not like they're not
very fun it's a adaptation period as
well becoming
keto adapted and i can imagine that my
body has not had to produce
many ketone bodies over the last 10
years
so i think that yeah if you're healthy
though you might not have a hard time
like you might not if you're healthy if
and you sound pretty healthy if you can
survive off of garlic bread that's
amazing
they're saying this this was when i was
in my early 20s like now
you know i sometimes stretch and pull a
muscle so being 30 going north of 30
there's a lot of things i don't tell you
about
you know i i had to stop drinking red
wine when i hit 30 because it kept me
awake at night
and oh yeah
when you're young everyone's like oh
when you get old life gets worse you're
like nah
then you hit you've got this to come
when you hit 30 you're like
it it's it's just difficult maybe maybe
that could be something that pushes me
down this part you don't know
i might have to do like i said you're
off off off air i said you know what i
should give this a go because i love
moaning about things i love i take so
much pleasure
you could moan a lot yeah uh yeah and
just come into here and be like this is
[ __ ] this is annoying i'm [ __ ] hungry
i miss bread
steak sandwich missing it all day yeah
yeah yeah um i've only gotten healthier
and i am 29
just so you know i credit diet to that
yeah i think so it might push you into
diet at some point
yeah perhaps we could we could give it a
go we'll see how it goes
we can we can talk again later and see
see what happens i still haven't
forgiven you over the jason fung thing
what was it that resonated with with his
message that you were like
this guy's great um
well when i was on a high carb diet
so that okay a couple things one there's
some evidence that
cancer spreads less fast
if you don't eat because you don't feed
it glucose same with if you're on a
ketogenic diet
there's evidence that you can
potentially affect
cancer cells because a lot of them
consume glucose
okay are there not cancer cells that uh
are fed by ketone bodies though
because i because i've i
i'm not 100 sure that's why i'm asking
because i'm pretty sure that there's
a straw man argument where people are
picking up their their kind of elements
they go oh well
cancer cells are fed by glucose but then
someone else was like okay but there are
other ones that are fed by ketone bodies
and that's honestly honestly that's so
far out of my area of expertise that i'm
not comfortable talking about it
like i i don't know from from what i've
seen i have seen case studies for people
on
ketogenic diets with it um
halting or slowing tumor progression
i've seen case studies um so you can
take that information and do whatever
with it
but specifically for jason fung the
reason i started looking into him was
because i was playing around with my
diet i was like
you know first first i was shocked that
i didn't need grains to survive because
i thought that you needed grains to
survive
i was at that point then then
i was like this paleo diet this is what
fixed me this is the answer
and then it stopped working and i went
on a carnivore diet and i was like what
the hell like i can survive off of meat
for an extended period of time that's
[ __ ] like so that just blew my mind so
i had my mind blown multiple times
starting with the medical system isn't
helping me oh my god
i can use diet to help my symptoms oh my
god i don't need to eat grains oh my god
i don't need to eat plants
right so it's just like so then i just
lost faith in absolutely everything i
ever knew
really was like the government does
anyone know what they're talking about
is anything real anymore
um and then i started i'd heard about
fasting and i'd seen some seriously
extreme fasting
and i was like meh okay i'll give that a
shot because i don't know
that's weird that people can do that so
i did some extended fast and i did a
couple of
long fasts just to see what would happen
realistically
um and how i felt on the fasts led me to
jason
fung because you do i mean it's skyr
it's pretty obvious you don't eat for a
while
um i didn't feel that bad not eating
which was surprising
if i if i kept my electrolytes up but
you're completely full of adrenaline
because your body's like
go eat so your adrenaline your your
adrenaline goes up
but it was like i could see better i
could think faster
and i'm sure part of that is to
encourage you to go eat
if you're not eating but so i started
looking into him that way and
i don't think well i like him
that's why i had him on my podcast have
you read his book
uh no the obesity code uh the thing is
that
like you say that the conversations are
being had with such complex topics that
nor you nor i nor many people uh
are actually qualified on i'm pretty
sure his doctorate was from kidney
is a kidney specialist um
but he started looking into kidney
disease because he was treating
diabetics and he was treating diabetics
by implementing fasting
however with these high level kind of
debates that are going on
it you've it's very easy to create straw
man arguments
at this top level because not many
people are going to be able to go oh it
doesn't sound right they just take it as
fact
you know you're like cancer cells tumor
glucose people like [ __ ] it all make
sense
you know they sit back they're like oh
my god and it's so easy to convert these
people
because you know people are now trying
to debunk all the other systems jason
fung is again someone saying that
cutting calories
won't help you lose weight and you know
i was like whoa you've got a bit carried
away uncle
you know hold on a second you might have
had you might have had some stellar work
in this field but you've kind of
overstepped it
and to me that's fair it just seems that
you know we
if he's gonna i know exactly what he's
doing he's trying to debunk the calorie
and calorie out model
and there's a lot of support behind him
for that but there's a lot of support
behind
a lot of movements that aren't great and
it's very easy for me to see his
narrative with these things
and if he's going to have a narrative
that defies thermodynamics
you know if he's gonna have a narrative
that defies [ __ ] physics
where else am i gonna put his moral
compass you know what i mean so
hold on mate you've literally just gone
on a video with someone who's got
uh over a million followers and spoken
openly about how reducing calories is
you know not a way to lose weight and
that
people have got hormonal issues or
whatever objectively
making these insinuations and claims
excuse to me like if he's gonna do it
this side i just can't imagine that he
wouldn't do it somewhere else
and ultimately the bottom line here is
book sales the bottom line here is
you know having this movement that goes
against the grain and
as soon as i see a [ __ ] in someone's
armor in one place
i can't credit the model
and for that reason it is one of those
things where
we'll we will agree to disagree on that
and i think that
it's probably as well because we're
button heads on things and you know if
he's helping people and if fasting is
helping those people
it that's fine and again it's not like a
war where
i have to conquer jason fung we're just
two people that
should be allowed to butt heads on
things because ultimately his team of
fasting hungry people that can't sleep
because their adrenals are [ __ ]
firing
you do you guys if you like that then
you [ __ ] do that
but then i've got my my camper people
over here they're like [ __ ] out i
lost six pounds in the last three weeks
eating cereal every day
you know what i mean so like we have our
camps we have our people
and you know even you know trish from
[ __ ] norfolk she's over there going
i had [ __ ] you know gluten every day
and i feel better because i've lost 15
kilograms and
it you know oh james my husband started
[ __ ] me again you know and i've
i've had unhealthy foods every day so
like we we always have these like
different camps for him
but you know i never try and attack
people based on uh
who they are what they're doing just
when they say things that aren't true
i'm not well that's not right mate you
know i get what you're doing
i get what you're saying but [ __ ]
don't get too carried away and
when people are left with these big echo
chambers you know
to say these things without
repercussions um
it makes it easier for people to keep
taken and taken and taken
yeah well that's part of the reason i
love social media and that's part of the
reason why we've been
i think dad in particular has been so up
in arms about freedom of speech
because you have to be able to see
everybody
right so if you have somebody saying
things and you don't agree with them you
need to be able to
you should be allowed to tell people why
you don't agree
and then other people should be able to
listen to that and and decide
who to agree with i i try and tell
everybody who's watching me
like i know that i have i i i'm
extremely biased
at the moment and that's because of the
experience i had with medical system and
so
and like i said my mind was blown so
many times that now i'm like
literally anything is possible like i'm
gonna be into
astrology soon it's gonna happen one day
like anything is possible
so i'm i'm totally aware of that um
and it's a problem but people should
just like people have to research
themselves they and they should look at
and if they're in an echo chamber like
if they're if everyone around them
agrees with them all the time
then they're in an echo chamber and they
should see what people outside of that
echo chamber are saying
otherwise they're going to end up like
what happened to me with oh i thought
one thing and it was completely wrong oh
i thought another thing and it was
completely wrong and then
your worldview just falls apart so you
have to make sure
that you're seeing everything around you
and you're not too
interested in one idea or in an echo
chamber
we're all to be our own best scientists
and like to figure out these things
because how you feel is is probably your
gold standard
but yeah the freedom of speech thing is
is massive where
we are moving away from a world where
we're allowed where we can be wrong
and that you know i shouldn't cancel
jason fung because he said something
wrong he shouldn't go disappear to the
corners of the earth that's a disservice
to the people that love what he does
but you know we're living in a world
where you're not even allowed to be
wrong on anything
ignorance is is disappearing and i
should have a privilege to be ignorant
to things if i
misunderstand feminism or i
misunderstand
uh you know something in a
you know whatever political
idea it is i should be able to be say
james we think you're wrong on this
here's a source to get into this is a
person you could speak to and
considering that we have this huge
network now of podcasting of people
uh talking on the internet of these
intellectuals coming in together
instead of counseling people or
silencing them or whatever we should be
able to
really work together to help people curb
their ignorance
you know and ultimately we're all
veering through life at a certain
trajectory and there should be
adjustments along the way and it's
it's annoying that you you can't almost
express yourself
fully without the fear of cancer culture
without the fear of being shut down
without the fear of the repercussions of
being wrong these days
and uh it's a worrying sight in which
we're going i know that
definitely last year with like the black
lives matter stuff some people posting
the blackout square and you know i was
getting criticism in my inbox why
haven't you posted anything i was like i
don't know what's going on
i was like i've not got a memo from
instagram
to post to black square i was like i'm
in australia i'm a day ahead of all you
[ __ ]
you know you they're campaigning for
that tuesday i was like it's 9 p.m i've
been posting all day you bastards like
where's my heads up
and um yeah it's it's crazy that you've
screwed with whether you're wrong
whether you're right and it's yeah
it's very difficult with that yeah i was
so annoyed about that black square
i was i was really stressed out i was
dealing with my dad's health and i woke
up in the morning and everyone had this
black square and i was like oh great now
i have to post a black square
and i was like wait um wait a minute
that's a very odd
thought to have i could wake up in the
morning see black square i'm like oh now
i have to post a black square
i don't have to post a black square i
don't like i don't have to post a black
square
and so i put up a post that was just
like you know [ __ ] this
guys this is ridiculous like if i wake
up in the morning i'm guilty about
posting a black square it doesn't even
mean anything it's not helping anybody
like are you all sheep anyway i want ham
on instagram a little bit but
the idea was that we were supposed to
create a void where
voices the but a black square isn't even
a void how about you don't post anything
like it's virtue signaling it was
everyone's trying to wave their flag of
like look how [ __ ] amazing i am
you know and again i had a big big post
this week about
virtue signaling and people trying to be
morally superior to other people and
they hide it under the guise of other
things like veganism
uh you know a lot of the people you know
the
uh i i like having a pop as well as uh
people with the
pronouns in the bios i was like what
have you done
for transgender people to support them
were you
at the last protest in the street you
know for their rights no you weren't
you literally just put pronouns in your
bio so someone comes across your page
and goes ah [ __ ] look at you
doing your bit you're an amazing little
person aren't you fantastic
can't wait for you to meet your parents
you know what i mean and um they're
always the one putting their [ __ ]
nose in your business
you know oh you used your phone when
you're in your car i was parked your
prick
[ __ ] off like you know
yes yes i agree okay
james where can people find you online
and
what are and give me a little bit of
information about your books
so um online james smith pt
i would love to get the pt out of that
but i've got a name that
is pretty common so it makes things very
difficult
uh first book not a diet book i was
actually
completely smashed with my publishers
harpercollins and
uh we had no name for the book they were
like what are we going to call this
because it's not a diet book
and that's what we ended up calling it i
was like that's it like hiccup in it
at the table i was like that's the name
and
because it wasn't a book of systems and
i've always said like
let's imagine a calorie deficit for fat
loss is over on the right
and let's say you're over on the left
people need
to understand the ins and outs the laws
of
physics thermodynamics about fat loss
occurs the the shroudy area in the
middle is systems
that are created to dress it up whether
it's fasting five to
keto low carb whatever and although they
could have purported health benefits
uh for purely fat loss they are just
people systems and then there's
you know the ways people hide their
systems to make it suit them
narratives using points and sins and
special recipes or whatever it is so the
book was about giving people
uh you know some clarification on that
but interestingly enough the
the parts of the book that resonated
weren't oh [ __ ] l james the way you
worked out my macros are amazing
i spoke about the sunk cost fallacy for
instance and i said that
you know people remain invested in
something based on their previous
efforts
not whether or not it's serving them
again when people use a shitty pt
that i've been within four years i can't
leave there's still a [ __ ] pt
and you know or with a partner oh we've
been together five years
yeah but you're still not happy in a
relationship or a job
and after that first book people coming
up to me and they're like james i just
broke up my partner seven years
i'm so sorry they're like no don't be it
was it was awful
they were dragging our heels we were
literally they read the chapter in the
book and went
i am remaining invested in this based
only on my previous investments
and it's the same reason people struggle
to walk away from you know financial
investments that go bad
so then when i was proposed for book two
i was like
i'm only going to talk about the
mistakes i think people are making in
life
like sun cross fallacy let's talk about
how people feel with imposter syndrome
let's talk about
uh you know income satiety where after a
certain amount
of income your life doesn't get better i
you know
i drive home this point in book two not
a life coach because i was like i'm not
being a life coach guys i'm not your
[ __ ] tony robbins like
yeah come on guys clap your hands it's
not like that
but i'm saying to people all wins in
life feel the same
and no successful people are really
communicating this where
when i was p.t in on the gym floor and
something good happened or my client got
a deadlift
pb that feels the same as becoming the
best on an author it's not like an uber
surcharge you don't get a 1.9 rating on
happiness
the signaling in our brains is is the
same and
as we go through life we got stopped
looking down
the lens of being rich and living in a
massive house and whatever because
ultimately
that version of ourselves in the future
20 30 years ahead are still going to
experience the exact same emotions we
experience now
so let's not just you know daydream
through life looking at this utopian
state because
what makes you happy today is going to
be the exact same as what makes you
happy in a few years time the the wins
you know selling my first pdf to 20
people
was just as happy as selling a few
hundred thousand copies of a book and
it was really to delve home that so the
second book was
about creating a lifestyle that you know
it builds around happiness and
distinguishing pleasure and happiness
where
people don't understand that happiness
is
swimming in the sea with my friend you
know having good friends and family
pleasure is expensive watches going out
buying a [ __ ]
gucci t-shirt that i have a nap in just
to piss off my haters on instagram
but if people can't differentiate the
differences between pleasure and
happiness they're going to really
struggle
and when people can do that it's almost
like a weird precursor to the first book
because
if they leave an unsupported partner
they pursue a job they enjoy rather than
the job that pays the most
and they construct a life based on their
wins they're going to have now
that whole dieting and going to the gym
and hitting your [ __ ] step count
isn't half as difficult when you're
happy
and it was a really powerful opportunity
for me in that second book to
try and help people not to get fitter
and healthier but happier not to worry
about the trivial [ __ ]
not to worry about the dick pic they
might have sent 10 years ago you know
like
and if you can create happy people that
have got good values i think that
everything else on top is just a lot
easier
so that's it and a bit of a nutshell
that was awesome okay that's a perfect
way to end it
i will link your social media and the
books in show notes for anybody to check
out thank you very much for coming on
that was fun
cheers thank you very much for having me
you